but I think really important is having
goals you know and putting literally
putting it like just somewhere visually
where subconsciously you sort of see it
but then you break it down into smaller
goals and smaller until it's so so small
that it's like it's the most easy task
like making your bed in the morning
taking a cold shower I don't know it's
like doing your dishes right after you
eat not just letting it sit in the sink
like that is the discipline that leads
to whatever bigger goal you have and
like that's what I if I if I'm
overwhelmed I just go back to the basics
back to the basics and then I remind
myself everything's baby steps and then
all of a sudden I end up where I was
supposed to go I'm like this isn't that
hard because I did all the right things
along the way